foreign  [Music]  ER how about you I started the whole  damn thing  oh  [Music]  we decided that you could have one gift  early  what is it that is a direct hotline of  Santa Claus himself  Santa all right revelers  welcome to your worst Christmas shopping  let's go  you have 300 million dollars in your  personal vault  for Christmas  [Music]  I don't want any trouble okay  Something's Gonna scooch up that chimney  who is he because he's not your typical  Mall Santa  are you there  daddy said you were very busy tonight  [Music]  are you gonna help us  Santa no my nice list  Santa Claus is Coming to Town  for some beatings  who the hell are you  boss what if he really is the real no  such thing as Santa  she's Batman  they're all my naughty list naughty  that's naughty  and what do you do to the naughty ones I  give my life a call  where is this  I believe in you Santa  come on  which one of you did that Prancer  so unprofessional  [Music]